I'm 1/4 the very last line in your book
under acknowledgments is the following
I thank my father Martin Westgate
McCourt for delivering me as Robert Penn
Warren wrote out of the history into
history and the awful responsibility of
time what are you getting at there well
if you can figure out what that that
quote means let me know because I've
been I've been pondering it for years
it's it's the last line from all the
king's men and the which was sort of an
inspiration for this book because as you
recall in that book the main character
is able to tie his own his own history
history to characters that he thought
had nothing to do with him when he was
growing up in this child of privilege so
the I would say the emotional impetus
for my writing this book was trying to
figure out my father and in trying to
figure out his personal history I was
able to figure out real history why did
you want to do that well he was a really
interesting figure to say the least he
was a damn really mobile
kind of renegade son of a civically
prominent family in Birmingham and he
just didn't make sense to me
he both wrote of this vigilante spirit
among the country clubbers and I wanted
to find out why he turned out the way he
did is he alive today he is has he read
your book he I think the last I heard he
was still reading it and he's really
proud of me
so what does he think of what you tried
to do and what's his reaction the way
you've characterized him I think he
feels that it was that it was honest and
and true and I think one of the reasons
he's taking it so well is that we always
had a very strong bond and it's not even
though I'm I reveal some perhaps painful
or embarrassing things about me it was
it was not done to vindictively it was
done in an attempt to understand painful
things about you or about him what's the
most painful thing you think you wrote
about him well actually the thing that I
was kind of most worried about was his
relationship he had a troubled
relationship with his own father because
his own father had been a a
harvard-educated big lawyer for the
power company
and I think he gave my father a fairly
short shrift when he was growing up so
he idly enough even though I reveal
things about my father's bigotry I think
that was the thing I was worried about
most in a way because I just felt that
that was the the the original wound in a
way that made him rebel against his past
his background what's the first thing
you can remember about Birmingham
Alabama
funny you should ask the first thing I
remember was we at the time if even
though my father was from Birmingham
when I was growing up we lived in a
small town in Cherokee County out in the
sticks and we would always come into
town to visit his mother my grandmother
and there was a an indoor all paint sign
that had these sort of goon like figures
with with with blue hair sprouting from
their heads almost like those troll
dolls that we see now and what he called
them bushy hair and when we saw bushy
hair we knew that we were near my
grandmother's health that and of course
Vulcan the largest iron man in the world
who held a neon torch that shone green
on days when there'd been no traffic
fatalities in Birmingham and red when
there'd been a traffic fatality that's
what this picture isn't about yeah you
say in the early part of your book that
did 1976 Bicentennial or a centennial or
something like that of Alabama's the
first reason why you got interested in
even doing this explain that well I had
grown up thinking that the cataclysmic
events of 63 which the book was the
climax of the book and the climax of the
civil rights movement had had nothing to
do with me the dr. King's demonstrations
there the fire hoses and police dogs the
church bombing I was growing up over the
mountain away from all that and just
felt totally alienated from that and the
book that you mentioned was this the
Alabama vol in a Bicentennial series on
the 50 states and it had a very brief
account of the troubles in Birmingham
and I realized for the first time
reading that that that a man named Sid
Meier had been the only white man in
town he was a businessman who would
agree to let his name be used
in the negotiations with dr. King and I
screamed to my apartment in Cambridge
Massachusetts
that's my cousin and it was the first
time I ever realized that this had
anything to do with me and it embarked
me on this this journey home here's a
picture of him who was he is he still
alive he's not alive
he was seen out by the time I started
doing my research but I knew his son and
grandson quite well he was a he was a
businessman who had and it ended up
realizing he was the protagonist of the
book because he sort of touched every
quarter of the book he was he started
out as a one of the big segregationist
architects of the Dixiecrat secession
from the from the Democratic Party in
1948 when the South seceded from the
party was this big it was compared to
the original secession it was so
important he was the sponsor and
impartial bankroll er of one of the most
rabid racist racist demagogues a man
named ace Carter who then came to fame
as Forrest Carter the author of a
best-selling the education little tree
and finally he became the friend of the
civil rights movement and he went
through some strange a process of faith
and redemption that I never quite
understood either but he he switched
sides and ultimately did the right thing
the 16th Street Baptist Church bombing
this is recorded several ways for its
aired but last night on the radio I
heard at in the middle of reading this
book it's still an issue from 1963
what's going on there well it took it
took a long time to bring any case
because for several reasons one is that
the evidence is just really weak the
arch perpetrator of the crime
dynamite Bob Chambliss was convicted by
the state of Alabama in 1977 but since
then the four other suspects chief
suspects in the crime were they never
could build enough evidence on them
nobody involved in the case has ever
talked about it so they said we may
never know what really happened
leading up to that explosion also the
investigation initially was very
compromised Birmingham was the
johannesburg of America at the time it
was the most segregated city in America
v the Birmingham police was in cahoots
with the Klan they had a long tradition
of collaboration and even some of the
members of the Klavan who perpetrated
the the the bombing had been under the
protection of the police so that so that
investigation was was flawed as well as
the FBI's initial investigation what
happened on that day what was the exact
date do you remember oh sure it was
September 15th 1963 and the schools of
Birmingham had just been desegregated
over the last the previous couple of
weeks so it was President Kennedy was
president and George Wallace was
governor and Wallace had called out the
state troopers to try to block the young
school children from entering the
schools in Birmingham and it I believe
really given a signal to the
segregationist that they could go ahead
and do it was necessary to stop the
desegregation of the schools what what
had happened was that President Kennedy
had introduced federal legislation to
outlaw segregation as a result of the
big demonstrations there with the police
dogs and fire hoses that spring so the
Klan realized that their franchise was
was running out and they were going to
do anything to stop integration from
coming about and they ended up bonding
the church to do that what was the Klan
what was the clan the clan was a very
interesting terrorist arm of the
establishment for a very long time and
it has started out in the 20s in earnest
as a sort of oddly enough the liberal
arm of the Democratic Party it was sort
of this this insurgent radical populist
sort of incarnation of they have not
goods for power over the previous couple
of decades that explains how Hugo black
the great civil libertarian Supreme
Court justice had his political career
launched by the Klan because he was part
of this insurgent
arm of the party so Hugo of course
becomes an avid new dealer and Supreme
Court justice and in the meantime the
Klan becomes the terrorist arm of the
anti new dealers they are to fight the
Union to to tar it with with racism and
and or tore it with that it's trying to
promote social equality among the
workers and then finally by the 19th so
they the industrialist of Birmingham the
heavy manufacturing industrialists who
who owned the city had encouraged this
because the last thing they wanted was a
strong labor organized labor so they
encouraged the Terrorism to to disrupt
labor and then finally in the late 50s
the terrorists become bad for business
because the economy is changing is
moving away from heavy manufacturing
towards service and the the industrials
the business community starts disavowing
the Klan but it's too late they've
they've they've let this force loose in
the community and they can't call it
back and then that leads up to the
church bombing in 1963 how many people
lived in Birmingham I think in the city
proper there are about 250,000 what was
the racial mix about 40% black I don't
know whether you say it or not but I
think you do is the most segregated city
in the world that's what was it was it
was confiture Highness bird of America
and and dr. King called it the most
segregated city in America well how
would that be though what were the
things that blacks and whites that were
exceptional in Alabama they had
segregated parking lots and as one of
the sources in my book said why would
they why would they have to segregate
the cars they can't have sex so because
that's kind of what it all boil down to
and why was it so strong there did you
learn that in your study oh yeah because
it was because it went back to this
industrial this industrial base there
there was a very strong economic motive
to enforce segregation rigidly to foment
racial strife to keep it what it boiled
down to was keeping the labor force
divided so that they could keep wages
down they can have the white workers
identified with management
and they [ __ ] the Union as they inward
Union so that to try to try to repel
whites from from joining now it's took
you 15 years to do this 1919 yeah what
were you doing during those nights well
I had to say that five of the years were
spent cutting the book because the
original manuscript was Believe It or
Not three times longer than within what
you have in your hand there so and
you're talking about a book that 700
pages mm-hmm it was the original
manuscript was thirty four hundred pages
and so you know I had to get I cut it I
cut it I ruined it I started over
started over again and and finally I I
was able to figure out a way to tell the
narrative in a in a more streamlined
fashion although all the reviews have
called it exhaustive anyway and I think
oh no this is like the Cliff Notes
version of it where were you living when
you did the work on I was living in
Boston to begin with that's where I was
living when I read this account assets
Meyer and I was I had been working for
an alternative weekly there and
eventually was the editor of Boston Matt
of managing editor of Boston Magazine in
Boston what was the name of the
alternative weekly the Boston Phoenix
and how did you get into journalism in
the first place well I was a literature
major in college and the only thing I
felt qualified to do when I graduated
was read eBooks
so that's what I started reviewing books
for the Boston Phoenix and then and then
as a result of that just sort of moved
into future journalism and and taught
myself on the job
where do college I went to Wellesley
where my grandmother had gone so I was
destined from birth to go there and what
was your dad doing when you went to
college
what was his work he was a he had a
small business
rebuilding air compressors for to to
fill scuba tanks for recreational use he
was an avid scuba diver what was your
relationship to him back in those days
in college we were actually that was our
most estranged period I had sort of
entered the cut the counterculture once
I moved to Boston I was in the early 70s
and he during the Vietnam War and he was
we we really fell out over the war and
he was sort of the the Archie Bunker tie
and we went for a few we had a few rough
years there where we didn't speak very
much now there's a name that pops out of
this book almost out of nowhere that we
know in this town Margaret Tutwiler yeah
she was my sorority sister we're at at
Brook in the brook Hill school for girls
in Birmingham she was a class ahead of
me and she it turns out that her family
she was from one of the founding
families of Birmingham they found a
family in Birmingham and it's pronounced
debarred Laban and that's actually
Margaret's middle name and she and her
family are major major characters major
players in the book why well they were a
very prominent coal coal family because
they were coal operators they like they
were the fifth largest producer of
commercial colon in the in the country I
think I mean they were quite big and
they had become during the New Deal the
sort of staunch anti-ro Savelle family
in the south they had bankrolled a lot
of of anti-union anti New Deal
propaganda and and and Charles de
bar-lev and Margaret's
great-great-grandfather had become this
anti-union icon nationwide he was the
only major coal operator to resist John
L Lewis and the United Mine Workers I
hate to keep him out of his camp
she's slated to be the ambassador to
Morocco used to be a spokesman for the
Bush administration at the State
Department Margaret yeah do you know her
very well I don't know her well I mean
we weren't very close growing up our
families were very close like my aunt
and her mother were in each other's
weddings in in this book you have
pictures of a lot of the characters if
you're my age you remember the names and
some of the pictures do you remember
them when 63 you would have been how old
I was 10 and 63 I don't I I didn't
I was totally ignorant of what was going
on and it turns out that I mean I ended
up getting to another when I interviewed
them for the book this is a picture here
of a man named Bull Connor who was he
Bull Connor was
most people know him as the the cartoon
villain of the civil rights era he was
the police commissioner of Birmingham
who was the the perfect enemy for the
civil rights movement he's the one who
sticked the dogs and fire hoses on
Martin Luther King's child demonstrators
in the spring of 63 he what I yeah one
of the purposes of the book was try to
present the segregationist and in full
dimensions and try to really explain who
they were why they were how they came to
act seemingly against the values of
their Christian culture and it turned
out that Bull Connor had been installed
in City Hall in the 1930s by the
corporate interests of Birmingham as
sort of a stop to the the Nasus because
they were the industrials were trying to
figure out a way to turn the grassroots
against the New Deal and Bull Connor
turned out to be their anti New Deal
mascot so they put him in City Hall who
was Fred Shuttlesworth fresh Ellsworth
is my hero he's the hero of the book
he's the he was a very confrontational
militant Baptist preacher who led the
civil rights struggle in Birmingham he
was known throughout the civil rights
movement as the wild man from Birmingham
because he was sort of crazily
courageous he put himself in harm's way
in order to test God to see if God was
going to protect him his his church had
been bombed in 1956 the they bet he was
lying on flew up like a magic carpet and
he came out unscathed so he really felt
that he was anointed to lead the fight
and and ended up being a really
important figure where's my guy he has a
church in Cincinnati Ohio you talk to
him about this Oh a lot a lot I'm glad
he's still alive to to see his story yes
the most important thing you learned
from anyways you were talking to him
well what I really learned was that how
important he was in pushing keying into
into greatness that if it hadn't been
for Shuttlesworth we probably wouldn't
be celebrating a national holiday for
dr. King today why is that um King was
coming into Birmingham what had been
extremely passive and unfocused he there
was a sense that he really
do not want this to accept this mantle
of leadership he which which almost
seemed it makes it even seem more that
he was this man of destiny it was
Shuttlesworth who kept pushing him he
said you've got to get off the lecture
circuits stop talking to the white
people you've got a lead you know you've
got to you've got to galvanize the
people and in lead us to the promised
land because he realized that he had the
authority to do that
Shuttlesworth says it was always pushing
he was the vanguard strategic Vanguard
of the movement he was the one who
pioneered direct action by disobeying
unjust laws as opposed to just passively
resisting them and he was just a major
figure who hasn't gotten credit in most
accounts of the movement who's this man
right there with the tie on and that
code open a Gary Thomas Rowe the kind of
boozy looking guy that was the reason
that the FBI's investigation of the
church bombing was flawed this was the
FBI's chief informant inside the most
violent clav urn in America the Eastview
13 clapeyron based in Birmingham let me
stop you to ask you about what's a
Clavin a Clavin is like a club one of
the the small groups of a Klansmen it's
sort of a subset of the
state-of-the-state clan and Eastview 13s
all through your book what is that ESP
13 is the name of this of this very
violent clan Clavin
clan club based in Birmingham did you
talk to anybody before the book that had
been a member of that clan oh yeah oh
yeah
anybody that how about your family um
were they members well I kind of my
hands went clammy when I was reading
these FBI informants reports and I came
across a man named loyal McWhorter and
my last name and I thought wow you know
my father that just sounds just like a
dame he would make up because it was
kind of mythical and romantic and
everything and so there are a few there
I I had some some tough weeks thinking
that that might have been my father but
it turned out there was a real loyal
McWhorter and he was probably a country
cousin a man
that I ended up talking to his brother
and loyal was murdered by his girlfriend
while lying in bed and any I guess it
was such a bad person that the
girlfriend got off did you ever ask your
father point-blank were you a member of
the clan oh yeah oh yeah absolutely he
never gave me a straight answer I know
he wasn't a member of the clan but he
never told me what he was doing on those
nights when he was out at his quote
civil rights meetings fighting the civil
rights movement I I never quite there's
a there's a verbatim transcript of my
interview with him in the epilogue
trying to pin him down and he he just
would never quite tell me why I don't
know I think maybe one of the sort of
touching things he said to me was that
he said I'm afraid I didn't do all the
things you may have thought I did is if
I was hoping that he had done the worst
and he almost apologized that you know
that he wasn't gonna to offer up any big
big punch line or something and it was
sort of touching but kind of frightening
Ling grandiose that he would have
claimed false credit or blame for for
some of this clan criminal activity that
he had really hadn't participated in the
transcript in the epilogue starts with
you knew shamless I said that meeting
you I knew him all he said you knew Gary
Thomas Rowe you questioning him I knew
them all so who bombed the church you
asked he gave me a half lidded look and
trotted out the old chestnut it was the
janitor that's not the only time I saw
that in the book right you read it I'm
impressed
he passed the pop quiz if I was the
janitor so what's that why would they
always give that answer there was a lot
of people thought that that blacks had
Blount had had bombed their own church
in order to get publicity for the
movement that was just a very popular
theory among thinking people as well as
sort of the nut cases so the janitor had
been called in for questioning by the
FBI and
because of that and I'm not sure whether
he was the suspect in their minds or not
but he was he was questioned by them so
as a result of that there was this
popular theory came now that the janitor
had done it you spent a lot of time in
the book telling the story of the
bombing itself
have you gone around and talked to
people how many people remember it
the adults remember it one of the
reasons I wrote the book was because I
didn't remember it I have I don't
remember when I found out about it it
was almost as if I'd always known but
the Canon President Kennedy was
assassinated too much two months later
and of course I remember everything
about that so I know it wasn't just that
I was too young for it to register and I
really wondered why it was it's
something that had happened a couple
miles from my house and had not
registered on my consciousness at all is
the church there today it is what goes
on there what's still called the 16th
Street Baptist Church that's across the
street now from a really great museum
the Civil Rights Institute and the
church has been restored a lot of the of
the stained glass was damaged in the in
the bombing it's looking for an identity
it was even looking for an identity at
the time ironically it was the 16th
Street was the it was the seat of the
black bourgeoisie and and they had been
pretty hostile to King they they had
made their accommodations with
segregation and kind of didn't want to
rock the boat they had to they had too
much to lose it was it was the masses
who didn't have to risk that much in
order to participate in the struggle and
Reverend Shuttlesworth was very
unpopular with the black middle class
because he was he was a math leader and
there was a big division between the
black classes and the black masses the
the the masses were called them asses
because they they were an embarrassment
to these to the striving elements of the
community who had had really made great
strides and and didn't want to just
really didn't want to risk that
so that was the 16th Street was very
much in that tradition and they had let
the movement use the church grudgingly
so September of 1963 mm-hmm
President Kennedy's in office what else
is going on in the world and it has this
issue been much in the news
oh very much the Civil Rights Act what
became the Civil Rights Act of 64 was
big debated in Congress at the time in
it and it was looked like it might be a
losing proposition there was just you
know Wallace George Wallace had been up
screaming about it the civil civil
wrongs bill or something what's this
picture that's oh that's a George
Wallace that happened in the previous
June that's George Wallace standing in
the schoolhouse door he had run for
governor on a pledge to halt segregate
the desegregation of the schools of
Alabama even he had to stand in the
schoolhouse door so there he is facing
down the Deputy Attorney General
katzenback and in that September day on
that Sunday morning as paint the
atmosphere and the chart yeah the sunny
school adjust was winding down and a lot
of the kids Sunday School classes were
taking place in the basement a few girls
go into the bathroom to prep look hi
missus this is like 10:15 in the morning
and normally these girls would have gone
to a drugstore to get a coke before the
church service but on this day the
pastor was inaugurating a youth day
because he was trying to breathe new
life into the congregation which was so
her stale and stodgy so the girls three
of the girls were wearing white for
their roles as uh sure's for this youth
day and they were gonna be singing the
choir and everything Denise McNair
Carole Robertson Addie Mae Collins and
Cynthia Wesley and they were printing
because I wanted to look really nice
they were calling their hair in the
mirror and one of the another one of
their Sunday school classmates came into
the bathroom and said something like
they need to get back to Sunday School
class because those who don't obey the
Lord live only half as long and at 10:22
this bundle of dynamite that had been
against the east wall of the church
exploded and it
blew out a man-sized hole in the in the
wall of the bathroom blew the clothes
off the girls back then like cordwood
under debris and killed the ball when he
been decapitated did you talk to the any
of the fathers and mothers and you you
tell some stories that mean they can
remember I mean what would tell the
stories about going to the morgue and
finding that you know that well in one
case the most of that was actually from
FBI documents interviews with witnesses
on the scene because the the families
are have a hard time talking about it it
means Michael Lee did his movie about it
and they were willing to talk about it
but about the health were little girls
about that or what the church bombing
the the pastor when when they came upon
the girls did he didn't recognize them
because he thought they looked like
women in their 40s and and he couldn't
figure out who they could be because he
knew that they were there had just been
kids downstairs so the owner of a dry
cleaner across the street from the
church came up and he saw he looked at
the shoe the foot of one of the girls
and he said Lord
that's Denise and it was his 11 year old
granddaughter Denise McNair and that's
Denise yeah and so that was the first
time the past or realized that these
were children and the other one of the I
think it was the the father of a wet of
denieth Wesley I mean if Cynthia Wesley
also recognized her shoe sticking out
from a from the shade and this makeshift
morgue at the hospital so those were the
the the clothes had been there sort of
last thought on earth and that was what
ended up being blown off them and in one
case but identifying them what happened
is in the aftermath of that of the
charge well the the area was sealed off
that the white people were more worried
about rioting blacks that seemed and
they were about the victims
the the only thing that I was able to
find out about night I found out for my
mother's date book that I had been in a
Civic production of The Music Man the
musical and my rehearsal that night was
cancelled because we were afraid that
that the black people would be out
abroad in the streets hurting white
people so it as it turned out it was two
more black children who were killed that
day one by a police bullet and one by
two white teenagers who happened to ride
by this paperboy and shot him off the
handlebars of his bike so it was it was
a really tense situation Martin Luther
King came back to town President
Kennedy's emissaries came back to try to
keep the peace and there were high-level
meetings at the White House that night
to try to to figure out how to deal with
the situation weather troops should be
sent in or you know or just how to how
to keep a lid on things what have you
found out about J Edgar Hoover in all
this Jurgen Hoover was was a pretty bad
guy and he was part of it I think it's
doing for the fact that he was at the
totally bureaucratic creature and and he
hits the mind as if his main goal in
life was to protect his Bureau from any
kind of criticism so whenever they would
come under criticism from somebody he
would try to find a scapegoat and
there's it happen and in several
instances that scapegoat was Martin
Luther King so he had gone off on this
vendetta against him that was so sort of
it was so ugly compared with the fact
that this plan informant Kerry Thomas
Reilly was picture she showed earlier
was being shielded by the by his Bureau
and and because they were afraid of his
cut that his cover would be blown they
shielded the criminal activity he
participated in and his Klan brothers
from prosecution for various crimes so
the combination of going after King and
then protecting the Klan is just as one
of the the ugliest chapters in the
history of the Justice Department what
did the FBI do after the bombing the FBI
did they they they called out a manhunt
that that they were comparing to
Dillinger to try to find them and they
quite a thorough job except that because
they were afraid the Gary Thomas Rowe
might have been involved they told him
to stay away from the scene for a week
because they didn't want him to show up
in somebody else's investigative files
when they were showing pictures of
suspects to witnesses they did not show
rose picture or a picture of his car so
they were they were concerned that he
might have been involved because he had
been involved in other terrorist actions
that the Klan had carried out I
concluded that he probably wasn't
involved in the church bombing I'm not
sure whether he knew about it or not but
I don't think he took part of that years
later I run an account about how there
was a secret FBI investigation I mean
years later from 63 that people went to
them and they and this thing it's been
going on all these years well how did
how did it stay alive all those years
yeah it the the suspect the five main
suspects including the one who was
convicted and the two who are going on
trial are were were suspects from
virtually from day three and they just
could not build they could not build a
case against them the evidence was you
know nobody talked there the physical
evidence in a bombing is always
virtually non-existent because they it's
blown up you know what they soon as
there's evidence of a timing device but
rarely and it the investigation went
through fallow periods and then some you
know eager police chief or Attorney
General would reactivate it and then
come and come up against the same
problem which was which was lack of
evidence and it happens that these two
suspects one went on trial probably as
this airs and one going on trial if he
if they deem him mentally competent the
most of the evidence against them is
self eliminating statements they that
they make to third parties there's
there's really no new evidence about the
crime itself
in the epilogue of your book again you
talk a lot about your dad where's your
dad lived now he lives outside
Birmingham and he's you know virtually
retired and
your mom a lot mm-hmm now you're he's
not married or anyone correct you said
that he's at different ways that he's
lived his life and you talked about it
is he living a trailer now he doesn't
live in a trailer now he did one of the
most humiliating moments of my youth was
when I found out that my father was
thinking about moving us to a trailer
now I was you know I was going through
this private girls school that my
grandmother had founded and you know it
was this sort of star student and and
doing everything right and then my
father was thinking about moving us to a
trailer and I thought I just remember
thinking I could never live this down we
didn't move to a trailer but eventually
he and in the 1970s he lived in a
trailer for a while
got it out of his system didn't stay too
long why did he want to do that I mean
what was the motive I think it was he
grew up in this big house on a hill big
mansion as my daughters call it and I
think he wanted to get as far away from
there as they could and the trailer
seemed to fit the bill when you were
growing up how did he talk about blacks
both your mother and father about blacks
in the home and how long were they
married when you were growing up they
divorced when I was at college so they
were they were together during my entire
childhood we were taught polite children
were taught you never use the n-word I
mean it just was not a nice thing to say
my father did use the n-word and I think
that was I think I sort of rejected his
politics almost on class grounds before
I did on moral grounds because I just
found this so offensive that he for his
for our social class to use this word
this is what sort of lower-class White's
used I found out much later that guess
what the grown-ups did use that word
just as they swore you know but they
didn't do it around us so my mother was
I my mother was from Mississippi so she
wasn't really tied into the new
Birmingham Society at all and she was
she's just a really nice person who
would never be cruel to anybody and and
that she sort of lived that ethic
whether it was to a you know a white
person or a black person that she
didn't have any political take any
political political stance on the race
issues you have brothers and sisters had
two brothers where are they today
they're ones in Birmingham and I think
he was thinking about changing his name
when my book came out and I think think
they're all happy now and not as big a
bombshell as they feared and my younger
brother is in Macon Georgia what were
they afraid of I think they were just
afraid of the reaction and that it was
gonna be so hostile that they might
suffer some reprisals hostile for what
reason because I named names in the book
and it's it's a pretty unforgiving look
at a lot of people that we know as it
turns out most of the they're really bad
people from the book or dead I've gotten
some sort of sad San reaction from The
Namesake sons of some of the people who
were named in the book who were really
upset about it and my uncle has been
dissing me in the paper there because he
is this your uncle is it Hobart yeah he
was you know he was the the guy who
carried on the family name and he was a
very prominent lawyer in town and sort
of a country-club wit and everything and
and I think and he still he still is
very much part of the community and very
visible part the community so he what do
you think of him he he was very close
I'm very close to him he was sort of a
surrogate father to me and so I was a
little hurt when he when he told the
Birmingham News that he said Diane has
written an effective largely fictional
book so they asked him what he thought
was fictional no they didn't as a matter
of fact I was a little upset with the
Birmingham news about that - was he at
Klansman I know oh no no no no he would
never that would that would be totally
beyond the pale for somebody like him so
what was what doesn't he like about it I
mean is that you talk about the Mountain
Brook Club yeah and the Birmingham
Country Club
explain what that's all about well the
book opens on the day of the church
bombing at the Mountain Brook Club which
was sort of the sanctum sanctorum of the
Birmingham elite
and that's what my family was a member
of not my father but my grandfather had
been one of the charter members and my
uncle is one of the the the mainstays of
the club so I think that he was really
upset about what I said about the club
that's what that's what he was really
upset about it's in this beautiful piney
Valley in Mountain Brook which is this
suburb that with it was called over the
mountain because there was this kind of
barrier between the gritty City and this
beautiful suburb it's really one of the
most beautiful places in the world and
the club was just this bucolic
plantation style place where the the big
needles went has they that's what the
big industrialists were called and you
know just had their cocktails and so
what was wrong with that for me yeah I
loved it there what's wrong with it now
about what are you oh I don't I don't
know why he was so offended about what I
wrote about it
I think I said that the the Mountain
Brook Club members sort of disdained the
Birmingham Country Club members and I
said that it was the difference between
the difference between the two clubs was
was the difference between Kiwanis which
ran the city and rotary which owned it
and I don't know what problem he has
with that but seems to be true to me but
you did describe the fact that the clubs
had black waiters what was their
relationship with the members and what
happened in the Mountain Brook Club the
day of the bombing
well the the nampara Club waiters were
you know it was the sort of classic
paternalistic members of the family like
members of the family relationship and
they they got a lot of perks you know
free legal advice my my uncle freely
gave of legal advice to club waiters and
also the african-american family that
worked for our family and for his family
growing up so it was sort of you know
was the classic genteel relationship
that enabled segregation is to feel okay
about it because they had a genuine
relationships with black people and also
they had relationships that were civil
and kind
that was a way that they were able to
overlook the systemic systemic brutality
of the system itself so if you went to
the Mountain Brook Club today what would
you see compared to what you would see
in 1963 well you know I went there when
I was down there and people couldn't
believe that I showed my face in there
but I did you would see oh just a boat
oh I stayed about first day for a few
hours but it was a bingo night which
meant there were a lot of young families
there so they were either people who
didn't know me or didn't care it
wouldn't have cared about the book but
the waiters were glad to see me did you
do this after before you wrote the book
well I go back I would go back there
usually every time I went home while I
was writing the book but no when the
book came out and I was on my book tour
down there
I went down there to to pay a visit and
do they all know who you were I mean
that waiters know who you were some of
the all-time waiter said yeah oh yeah I
interviewed a number of the waiters and
so yeah they recognized me and so what
was the reaction when you went to
Birmingham and I had your book in hand
and went to the book stores and and how
much of a tour did you do there I did an
extensive tour and I went on a lot of
sort of right-wing radio talk shows too
right way uh-huh
and the the the reaction has just been
fascinating I would say the typical
reaction is and this sort of sums up
Birmingham is is why did why do you want
to drag that up again after 20 after 38
years I mean why do people care about
Birmingham the people the white people
in Birmingham just haven't quite gotten
that this was the most important place
and the most important story in in
American history perhaps and so finally
I came up with an answer which was would
you would you question why people would
want to read about Gettysburg they would
say no no well this is the Gettysburg of
the second Civil War this was the
turning point battle and and I think
finally you know people are beginning to
accept that it's just not gonna go away
that this is this is history that was
made here and that people are always
going to be interested in it the other
reaction I gotten was just it has been
shocked that that all this went on I
mean tracing all the sources of the of
the system back to the New Deal and
and the labor the labor movement and the
anti labor resistance and stuff was I
think it's just been a big shock to a
lot of people in the knowledge Minh she
say my family Richard Rosen and Lucille
I'm sorry Lucy and Isabel McWhorter
Rosen were my boon companions on this
journey and made my life complete my
in-laws and big supporters Saul and
Carrie Rosen mm-hmm your husband what's
he do he is a writer of mystery novels
and nonfiction and has also worked in
television and where do all the Rosen's
live the residents are in Chicago and
and your family where do you live now um
Manhattan Manhattan Island New York and
besides writing this book what do you do
for out of full time basis well I did
write I hate to say it but I wrote this
book on a full-time basis but I raised
my two daughters I also write for the
op-ed page of USA Today ever written for
the New York Times for years and you
know I've occasionally done done
journalism while I'm doing this but this
really kept me busy how old are your
daughters they are almost 12
Lucy's almost 12 and Isabelle is nine
and what do they think of all this well
of course the my elder daughter just
cause me a loser and a crackhead and
whatever is the popular expression elves
of contempt and my younger daughter I
think thinks that people are gonna
recognize me on the street now she's
Sunday I kind of took the thanks to two
extreme positions they have any
relationship with your father or your
mother oh yeah yeah is it all of us come
up there to ever come up with did you
know family to get the earth
um not really I mean they they sort of
they've been kind of fast that I did
with my father too they haven't been
able to quite figure him out because
he's not he's not the typical
grandfather so they're they I'm not sure
they really know exactly what's in here
yet you went with your father get the
right page here Joe plays at Velma's
Velma's and you have this in your
epilogue again some transcript what was
what happened at Velma's well Velma was
the beer joint that my father would
repair to after work for many years and
so in the course of doing research I
found that one of the benefits of doing
research with him was that I really
realized a relationship with
because I had the sort of ulterior
reason to - it exposed myself to stuff
about him that Native one's been painful
so I've coming into his beer joint
Velma's and just listened to the guys
talk about you know use the n-word and
and and talk about Yankees and you know
the the same old stuff is that there's a
little exchange here he says somebody
says you're writing a book about
Birmingham one man said well tell them
it's about what it's about Papa said to
you it's mostly about 1963 you said and
then your father said it's about the
[ __ ] movement what did you do when he
said that probably you mean did I did I
correct Emma yeah you did you do when
you go back there and he talks that way
to you correct him I did for a long time
I did during my twenties I spent I told
my 20s trying to change him and then I
guess I spent my 30s and some of my
forties trying to understand him so I
kind of retired from by then I had
definitely retired from from the role of
trying to reform him I just decided it
wasn't my my job I'm you next paragraph
you said for the next hour at Velma's I
was treated to comments like quote you
know as far as I'm concerned you can
take all the [ __ ] and put them all in
a boat and ship them all back to Africa
and you know what you can send all the
Jews right after them oh now I think
[ __ ] are alright I think everybody
should own one or two or three of them
people in that that beer joint said that
to you they were they were talking to
each other and you know they were just
kind of they know that you were writing
a book um oh yeah I mean yeah I I think
I may be an even taking notes while they
were writing I think that was one of the
ways I was able to to be present in that
that I knew that I was not I was not I
was not part of it really can you figure
out why people want to talk that way
today these people were people who are
socioeconomically marginal and I go see
oh economically margin they were on the
edge on the edge and they this is what
makes them feel good and that's why the
the
the tear the Klansmen were the sort of
dregs of the society because they they
were a the most threatened by
integration because their their jobs
might they they might lose job actually
to lose jobs to to black people if they
weren't systematically discriminated
against and also because it was their
their way of feeling important that they
were better than somebody I think it's
called the nurse's ISM with small
differences you know that the more
you're the closer you are together the
the more you make of these tiny
differences now you say that your family
has a connection to a man named Robert
Welsh oh yeah Robert well it was the
founder of the John Birch Society and he
as it turned out was my grandfather's
roommate at harvard law school and he
introduced my grandfather and my
grandmother to each other what was the
John burger what is the John Birch
Society and well the John Birch Society
was this super conservative
anti-communist organization which was
supposedly an educational organization
to alert people to the communist menace
around the corner about to take over
America and it became sort of the
respectable alternative for a lot of the
segregationist in Birmingham to join
after you know they weren't they
certainly wouldn't be in the Klan and
they and some if I wanted to organize I
would often be part of the John Birch
Society because that was socially
acceptable later on in this epilogue you
say they didn't believe in a Russian
domination of this United States and
they didn't believe in the hierarchy of
the Union they believed that everybody
was responsible for what they did for
their own actions I always thought that
everybody is responsible for their own
actions if their actions ain't too good
they may need to do a little bit more
praying who's saying that that's my
father kind of trying to explain how why
you believed what he did and and why he
was part of this resistance he now says
that he had nothing against black people
and there's there there's a lot of stuff
in the book about his true relationships
with
with with black people he spent a night
in jail once on behalf of some country
club waiters because he had had seen a
carload of white people run a red light
and hit this car load of black waiters
from the Country Club and he told the
police what had happened and the white
kids who had hit the car the the waiters
car challenged him to a fight they had a
fight and it was my father and uncle who
went to jail for them so he did have you
know a complicated relationship with
blacks and he had he had real intimacy
with some black people but and he would
always say now that it was because of he
thought they were under the civil rights
movement was under the influence of
Communists that's why he felt like he
had to get involved any change in
Birmingham between 63 and 2001 Oh I mean
you just can't conceive of what it was
like in 63 yes I mean the change has
been just incredible and to me one of
the great lessons of this is that you
know people always said that even if you
you can't legislate hearts and minds
people are people human nature's human
nature and you can't just get rid of
this system overnight and guess what
they did they got rid of it overnight
and it was amazingly peaceful and that's
not to say that that Birmingham is not
still a segregated society it's not but
it's the Mountain Brook Club by the way
integrated you know I I don't think it
is I think that I think my uncle Hobart
was designated to bring a black guest
you know as a guest of a member but I
don't think they're any possibly it
possibly has to remember the whole Shoal
Creek conference controversy during the
PGA tournament there was a Country Club
in Birmingham that had to undergo
emergency desegregation in order to host
the tournament that sort of put the
country clubs on the on the spot and and
got a lot of scrambling for a qualified
black member one of the early I think
this is the photograph Monty already
photographed you talk about is this one
right here and then he tell us what
that's about
yeah that was that was the sort of
classic movement a picture of the
bringing him demonstrations that was a
police dog attacking a teenager named
Walter Gadsden and it was that it was
that photograph that that President
Kennedy saw and he said it naked
SiC and sort of galvanized the it just
galvanized the country behind this
legislation to abolish segregation I
compared it to Uncle Tom's Cabin because
there were it told the big truth about
segregation but there were a lot of
little misleading details in it for
example water Gaston it was not a
demonstrator he was playing hooky and
was just sort of you know one of the
bystanders he wasn't participating in
the movement
you also resurfaced someone in this book
that we don't hear much from anymore and
it's this picture right here man named
Chuck Morgan uh-huh who was he who is he
where is he
Chuck it was a he's one of the heroes of
the book he was a young turk lawyer in
Birmingham and some people in Washington
may remember him as the he was a head of
the ACLU for a while he was the sort of
flamboyant lawyer he actually went from
doing civil rights law to to the other
side he started representing
establishment firms but he did he do
that clients in eighties where does he
live now he lives in Florida he's
retired he's he's a it was a very
flamboyant liberal guy who he's claimed
to fame in Birmingham about which he
ended up writing a book was that after
the church was bombed he gave a speech
to a young something called the young
men's business club in which he he
blamed the entire community for it for
the crime and he was essentially running
out of town as my father put it here my
father were close friends growing up did
you talk to him for this book
oh yeah many times and what was his
attitude about what you're doing chuck's
hmm oh it kind of could have been more
pleased that the story was being told
you have a story and it's just one of
those things the incidents that happened
back during those days and may still
happen today about Tom King who ran for
mayor and the photograph oh yeah what
was it it was called this was one of the
the big mysteries of Birmingham politics
it was who Tom King was running for
mayor against I mean named art Haynes
who went on to fame as James Earl Ray's
first lawyer but he was the
segregationist candidate Tom King was
Chuck Morgan's candidate
they were they were the Liberals and
they Bull Connor Tom keen was meeting
with Bull Connor and one of our trains
that operatives had they paid a black
kind of they let let it black convict
out of jail paid him to go up to Tom
King and shake his hand and Tom King
when I interviewed him said he just felt
didn't wash over him because the black
man held his hand for you know like a
good ten seconds and then just walked
away and they got a photograph of it and
that was just the ultimate
socio-political taboo it was 261 and and
they the black photo of the prisoner was
waiting somewhere yeah in the hallway
and walked out and shook his hands right
grabbed you know and and normally you
know a canny politician would not have
shaken hands with the black man but he'd
been on the hustings for so long he just
took his hand out trying to you know mr.
King took his hand out and and it was
that photograph that pretty much cost
him feel at the mayoral election was the
19 years or were the 19 years worth it
you know I've been amazed at how quickly
I went from oh my gosh she's so pathetic
she can't finish a book in nineteen
years to great achievement Wow great
achievement so yeah this is this has all
been worth it I have to say in the
reviews and in your time out on the book
tour what's the best they said about you
what's the worst they said about you and
it does it ever hurt when they say the
negative on the book who are well I
haven't gotten much negative I haven't
got anything negative to my face I've
gotten you know a Klansman showed up at
a at a book signing I've got I've had a
few heart flutters but mostly you know
it mostly the reaction is just been
phenomenal it's you know somebody on
these right wing talk shows would call
up and say this should be required
reading for everybody in Birmingham you
know and and one you know and that was a
white suburban matron called to say that
and then the next caller was a black
person who said oh I know so many people
in the book and and and I you know this
is just an amazing you know account of
this sort of hidden history now your mom
and dad have been married for years is
your mom read this she hasn't read it
but she's my biggest PR agent she's
taken it all over town to the bookstores
and flogging it like crazy so she's
really she's a really proud what does
she think of your father from what she
read in the book or did you say
shouldn't read it at all well she kind
of knows I think what a lot of people
have done in Birmingham is just read the
personal stuff to see you know to see
about me and my family and possibly the
people they grew up with she I think she
I mean she was married to him so she
knows what a perplexing character he is
and I think she understands why why I
did this what's next for you another
book I think so I'd like to get a
political column I feel confident
writing columns you know that you can
get out and see the next day so I'd like
to do that for a while and and then I've
got a I got a few other book ideas like
what well one of them would be about
another city but I think I'd had away
from my kids to leave to leave home to
be able to do the research for that I
have a few I might turn to my mother's
family in Mississippi next our guest has
been dynamic quarter this is the way the
book cover looks carry me home and by
the way this picture was taken when and
what is it those are children bracing
themselves against the fire hose spray
and that was taken in May of 1963 in
Birmingham in Birmingham to Kelly Ingram
Park thank you for joining us my
pleasure